hello everyone my name is scp-049 join
me as i regard on the christmas story
this one is entitled the man who still
Christmas a children's story
all hail Christmas Eve the most onerous
of times full of roasts and full of
ptosis and the most festive of rhymes
with some fresh eggnog and toady and
cuca for mommy a Christmas like this is
not to shoddy but one Christmas day
almost did not come clear with a man of
great horrors aim to spread fear a
scalpel and grin and a swig of some gin
was all those nerve of this demon of sin
who knew I'd strike that merciless thing
for naught but fair chance could help
intervene the good ole foundation was
much radiation did try but found only
frustration so who was to save Christmas
that season of wonder since those who
had tried were all torn asunder the
famed GOC well maybe the MC and D the
world held its breath and who it could
be
then the deadliest moose with antlers
aflame came charging on in to change up
doc man's game with an A and a cake
right into man's dick moose brought down
the surgeon right quick and so Christmas
was saved with a kick to the nuts
the peasants so happy left out of their
ass they crowned the sweet moose with
freshly whipped MERS and feasted like
kings
on a great goose so all hail the great
moose lest you find their quick ire for
if they're not praised you're dying in a
fire or maybe by crushing or perhaps
even flushing but it's best to just
leave them a blushing
you
you